وقد حضر الامين العام لمنظمه الايجاد
وورفينا جيبو مما وصفها بالانعكاسات
الخطيره للازمه في السودان في المنطقه
والعالم واشار الى انها تتطلب تصرفا سريعا
من الايجاد لمواجهتها وتفادي وقوع المزيد
من الضحايا
نود ان نرى وقفا للعنف ونزيف الدماء في
السودان لان انعكاسات هذه الازمه على
المنطقه والعالم خطيره جمهوريه السودان
كانت احدى اكبر الدول التي تستقبل
اللاجئين في افريقيا والعالم ونتيجه
للنزاع القائم فيها نواجه الان مزيدا من
النزوح واللجوء ومزيدا من انعدام الامن
الغذائي كيف سيبدو المستقبل اذا لم نحل
بسرعه الممكنه هذه الازمه لذلك علينا
مضاعفه جهودنا لانقاذ اخواننا في السودان
وندعو الجميع للالتزام بواجبهم الاخلاق
بالسعي لتحقيق السلام في السودان
من جاءت حذر رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
متفكي من حرب اهليه في السودان اذا لم
يتوقف القتال فورا وقال فك في افتتاح قمه
الايجاد بجيبوتي ان الاوضاع التي تتفاقم
في السودان تهدد المنطقه باكملها
خطوره الازمه التي تتفاقم في السودان اتصل
الى تهديد هذا البلد والمنطقه باكملها كل
التحليلات تقول انه اذا لم تتوقف هذه
الحرب فورا فستندلع حرب اهليه وستعم
الفوضى وستنهار الدوله السودانيه هذه
الازمه هي بحجم لا يسمح باي انقسام او
تاجيل ندعو الى العمل السريع والموحد بناء
على التضامن من جانبنا وندعو لتوحيد جهود
المنظمات الاقليميه والقاريه وهذا شرط
اساسي للتعامل مع الازمه السودانيه وشرط
ايضا لتجنيد جميع شركائنا للموافقه على
هذا الحل الافريقي للمشكلات الافريقيه